What happens to clothes after being dropped
off at the dry cleaners is a mystery to most.
We know that our clothes come back a whole
lot cleaner than when we dropped them off,
but how?
And who first got the bright idea to clean
clothing without water?
The earliest records of professional dry cleaning
go all the way back to the Ancient Romans.
For instance, dry cleaning shops were discovered
in the ruins of Pompeii, a Roman city buried
by the eruption of Mount Vesuvius in 79 AD.
Those cleaners, known as fullers, used a type
of clay known as fuller’s earth along with
lye and ammonia (derived from urine) in order
to remove stains such as dirt and sweat from
clothing.
That process proved pretty effective for any
fabric too delicate for normal washing or
stains that refused to budge.
(In fact, the industry was so prominent that
there were taxes on collecting urine.
Fullers generally used animal urine and would
also maintain urine collecting pots at public
bathrooms.)
As for more modern methods, the biggest revolution
in dry cleaning came around in the early 19th
century.
Traditionally, Jean Baptiste Jolly of France
is generally named the father of modern dry
cleaning.
The story goes that in 1825, a careless maid
knocked over a lamp and spilled turpentine
on a dirty tablecloth.
Jolly noticed that once the turpentine dried,
the stains that had marred the fabric were
gone.
He conducted an experiment where he bathed
the entire tablecloth in a bathtub filled
with turpentine and found that it came clean
once it dried.
Whether a maid and an accident really had
anything to do with it or not, Jolly used
this method when he opened the often claimed
first modern dry cleaning shop, “Teinturerier
Jolly Belin”, in Paris.
However a patent for a process called “dry
scouring” was filed with the U.S. Patent
Office in 1821, four years before Jolly’s
discovery.
A man by the name of Thomas Jennings was a
clothier and a tailor in New York, and soon
the first African American to be granted a
patent in the United States.
(Previous to this, it was ruled that slave
owners were the rightful owner of any inventions
made by their slaves and could then patent
those inventions under their own names.
Jennings, however, was a free man.)
So while working as a clothier, he, like so
many others in his profession, was familiar
with the age old customer complaint that they
could not clean their more delicate clothes
once they’d become stained because the fabric
wouldn’t hold up to traditional washing
and scrubbing.
Jennings, thus, began experimenting with different
cleaning solutions and processes before discovering
the process he named “dry scouring.”
His method was a hit and not only made him
extremely wealthy, but allowed him to buy
his wife and children out of slavery, as well
as fund numerous abolitionist efforts.
As for the exact method he used, this has
been lost to history as his patent (U.S. Patent
3306x) was destroyed in an 1836 fire.
What we do know is that after Jennings, other
dry cleaners during the 19th century used
things like turpentine, benzene, kerosene,
gasoline, and petrol as solvents in the process
of dry cleaning clothes.
These solvents made dry cleaning a dangerous
business.
Turpentine caused clothes to smell even after
being cleaned, and benzene could be toxic
to dry cleaners or customers if left on the
clothes.
But all of these solvents posed the bigger
problem of being highly flammable.
The danger of clothes and even the building
catching fire was so great that most cities
refused to allow dry cleaning to occur in
the business districts.
In the United Kingdom, for example, dry cleaners
had smaller satellite stores in the city where
they took in customers’ clothes and then
those clothes were transported to a “factory”
outside of the city limits where the dry cleaning
took place.
The major risk of clothes and buildings catching
on fire because of the flammable solvents
led to dry cleaners searching for a safer
alternative.
Chlorinated solvents gained popularity in
the early 20th century, quickly leaving the
flammable solvents in the dust.
They removed stains just as well as petroleum-based
cleaners without the risk of causing the clothes
or factories to catch fire.
That also meant dry cleaners could move their
cleaning facilities back into cities and eliminated
the need to transport clothes back and forth
between two locations.
A chlorine-based solvent with the chemical
name tetrachloroethylene, or sometimes called
perchloroethylene, became the go-to solvent
for dry cleaners in the 1930s.
Originally discovered in 1821 by Michael Faraday,
“perc” could not only be used in relatively
compact dry cleaning machines, but also did
a better job of cleaning than any of the other
solvents of the day; it’s still the chemical
of choice for most dry cleaners today.
While perc is considered much safer than most
solvents used by dry cleaners in the past,
the Environmental Protection Agency (EPA)
in the United States is working to phase the
solvent out of the industry.
The EPA claims that while wearing clothes
treated with perc does not appear to be dangerous,
perc can be dangerous if accidentally released
into the environment as it’s toxic to plants
and animals.
Additionally, the EPA also notes that sustained
exposure to perc, such as by workers in the
industry, can cause health issues with the
nervous system, including potentially drastically
increased chances of developing Parkinson’s
Disease.
There are also studies done by the EPA that
indicate perc may be a carcinogen.
The International Agency for Research on Cancer
also classifies the chemical as a “Group
2A carcinogen,” meaning in their opinion,
it’s probably carcinogenic.
So how exactly is this chemical used to dry
clean clothes?
The process of dry cleaning fabric can vary
between dry cleaning companies; however, the
general method is as so: before placing the
clothing item in the machines, workers pre-treat
stains by hand, as well as remove any materials
that aren’t suitable for dry cleaning (for
instance buttons made of materials that may
dissolve in perc are removed).
The machine works in a similar fashion to
normal, in-home washing machines.
It agitates the garments and adds in the solvents
as it goes, cycling the solution through the
machine and a filter as the clothing is agitated.
Temperature is also typically controlled at
around 86 degrees Fahrenheit.
Next, the garments are either dried in the
same machine or workers move them to a separate
machine.
During the drying cycle, the temperature is
raised to about 140 degrees Fahrenheit, which
helps the chemicals evaporate off the clothes
faster, while still being low enough not to
damage the clothing.
In the end, approximately 99.9% of the chemicals
used are removed from the dry cleaned item
and recycled for use again in cleaning.
Once the clothes are dry, workers press the
clothes, potentially stitch back on any items
that had to be taken off, and put the clothing
into plastic bags for customer pick-up.